Speaker 1: I want to do just a brief interlude
here about Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell. This is
actually very interesting what's going on because
it's bigger than pillow. This is about Twitter
with the root. It's not even really a rumor.
With the news that in principle, Elon Musk is
going to be buying Twitter, although it's not been
approved, it may fall apart. And to be perfectly
frank, I'm a little bit more and more and more in
the direction of this may. This may never happen,
but that's a story for a different day. There
are lots of right wingers that are sort of
reinvigorated, who have been banned from Twitter,
who believe they're sure they're going to be back
on Twitter, that Elon personally is going to
allow them back on Twitter. One such person
is Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell, known colloquially
as Mike Pillow or just pillow for short.
He decided to evade his ban by creating a new
account and it lasted 3 hours. Now, remember,
even if Elon Musk plans to unbanned
Pillow, which we have no reason to think,
at least at this point, Elon Musk is not in
control right now. A Business Insider reporting
Lindell was banned from Twitter in 2021 over
election misinformation but rejoined the platform
Sunday. The account was quickly banned for
violating Twitter's ban evasion policy.
Jack Dorsey should be first in line for prison,
Lindell told Insider. Business Insider via text.
Hello, everybody. I'm back on Twitter. He
tweeted. My only account is Mike J. Lindell.
Please retweet, follow to spread the word. The
tweet also featured a video of pillow confirming
the account is his. All those other ones are fake
accounts and they've been using my name out there.
So we started this account. Please share it with
everybody. Let everybody know so we can get the
word out at Twitter in case they do take it down.
Thanks a lot for helping out. Three and a half
hours later, the account was suspended. So Twitter
has what's called a ban evasion policy. And if
you've been banned, you're not allowed to attempt
to evade it by making a similar account. Like if
my Pacman account was banned, it's not just the
account, it's me as a person that is banned and
we can like it or we can not like it. And I'll
talk about that in a second. I can't then go and
create. Dave Pacman. And if Twitter finds out that
that's actually me, of course they would be within
their terms of service to ban me again. Now, I do
want to say something about these Twitter bans.
I am sensitive to the idea that maybe
there shouldn't be bans for life.
I could be convinced of that. I think that the
Trump ban was completely correct and legitimate.
I think that the Lindell ban was completely
correct and legitimate. But I would be open to
the idea that the maximum ban is a five year ban
or a three year ban. I mean, people do change and
I'm not saying Trump will change, but also what's
acceptable changes and great examples are like on
YouTube. Policies around many issues have changed
over time. Early in COVID, there was one policy on
COVID material. Later it was different. I could go
on. You can get the idea. It's sort of in a way. I
mean, this isn't a serious I'm being honest. It's
not a serious. But when when you more seriously,
there are people doing time for drug
possession and later the penalties for
drug possession are reduced or possession is
decriminalized or possession is legalized.
And I think that that should be subject to review.
And that's why I like it when Joe Biden and others
have kind of gone back and exonerated
or commuted sentences on that basis. So
I think there's a good case to be made that
the lifetime ban on Twitter maybe is a bit
much. Maybe it should be three years, maybe five
years or something like that. It is not currently
the case and of course, pillow is evading the
ban. One other thing on Mike Pillow here. He was
interviewed at yesterday's Trump rally. He says
that he's spending 18 hours a day on this Trump
reinstatement stuff that's wild dominion.
Speaker 4: And machines and machine. And,
you know, it's been a it's been a crazy year and a
half. But John, how has your life changed? Person
I know your business and we'll get to that special
promotion you have for us in a second. But how has
your personal life changed since all of this?
I mean, it's 18 hours a day with us. You know,
I miss my grandkids. I miss my family, you know,
and and my nieces and nephews. I got to check,
you know, take advantage of when I can. But it's
I before I was I'm so in the family. It's like I'm
I'm pulled away from my home state of Minnesota.
Speaker 1: But he's spending 18 hours a day
going around talking about machines.
Speaker 4: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: And claiming that we're just a week
away from it all coming out, that that actually
makes me a little bit sad. It really does not
because Pillow's a particularly good guy. But
there's something a little bit sad about that